c and around the country
c-span is brought to you by your cable
or satellite provider
tonight's event marks the occasion of
malcolm x untimely death on february
21st
1965.
since 2002 the schomburg center has been
the home for to the malcolm x collection
of papers
photographs
audio and visual items as well as other
personal items
last summer we expanded the collection
and announced the acquisition of several
new items including the full
241-page manuscript of the autobiography
of malcolm x with hand-written
corrections and notes from both malcolm
x and collaborator alex haley
we all it also included a previously
unpublished chapter from the book
believed to be omitted from the
publication after malcolm x's
assassination
the 25-page typewritten chapter titled
the negro is thought to be one of three
unpublished chapters in existence
and last we also received a series of
literal and literary
fragments or short notes in drafts by
malcolm x written or typed on small
pieces of paper
next up we're going to have remarks from
sister aisha al-arawiyah
who has been a dedicated steward of
malcolm x's legacy
we know her around here as sister aisha
because she is also the program
administrator for the schomburg's
scholars in residence program she is the
founder of the malcolm x museum
creator of the betty shabazz awards
also
held by the women in islam where she
co-founded
she can still remember the first time
she heard malcolm x speak
in a recent article titled the fraud
unforgettable
how malcolm x legacy lives on in america
she relates that people walked out of
his lectures feeling empowered to make a
difference in their life right then and
there she said she would he she was
personally taken by his social critique
and his allusions to the struggles of
others around the world please welcome
sister aisha as she helps to set the
tone for this evening
good
evening sisters and brothers
uh it's wonderful to see you all here
again this year
we are going into our
second decade
here at the schomburg center hosting
these commemorations for
malcolm x
malika
and i'd like to ask you
to show your appreciation to the
schomburg center for stepping up and
hosting these kinds of events
continuously and continually
on our behalf so thank you very much
[Applause]
i'd like to ask us to take a moment
of silence
to remember
our
black shining prince please so a moment
please
thank you
you know there is a verse in the quran
that reminds us
not to think of people who are martyred
as dead
but to think of them as alive
though we may not perceive them as such
so i think that in the case of malcolm x
this is certainly true
uh we feel that he has grown
larger
now than ever before and that many more
people
not only here at home but around the
world
celebrate
this legacy and look to this
example
uh in the struggle
for freedom and social justice so the
world owes malcolm x a debt of gratitude
for his sacrifice and i ask us also to
remember
his family
and be supportive in every way that we
can
i also ask you
to be supportive of the schomburg center
for research in black culture as the
institution that stepped up decades ago
and allowed us to do this kind of
programming at a time when it was not
the popular thing to do but it was
certainly the right thing to do so i
encourage you to be supportive of this
institution
and
come back and look at the incredible
collection that we have certainly on
malcolm x as novella has shared with you
but the people who were around him as
you hear from the panelists also this
evening and other uh heroes and sheroes
of our time and before so again i
welcome you to the schomburg center and
i thank you for
being consistent in your love for
malcolm x hajj malika shahbaz salaam
thank you sister aisha
as you will see our panelists represent
a cross section of scholarship and life
experiences they are here to help us
consider potential new insight from our
recent acquisitions and to discuss the
lasting impact of the autobiography of
malcolm x so first please welcome our
moderator dr vanessa k valdez
dr valdez
is the director of the black studies
program at the city college of new york
cuny a graduate of yale and vanderbilt
universities her research interests
focused on cultural production of
peoples of african descent throughout
the americas the united states and latin
america including the caribbean and
brazil she is the author of oshun's
daughters the search for womanhood in
the americas and the most recent
diasporic blackness the life and times
of arturo alfonso schomburg
next please welcome zaira ali
[Applause]
in february 2015 zaira lee was featured
narrator and cnn's one hour documentary
witnessed the assassination of malcolm x
and authored the accompanying essay for
the documentary's website he has taught
college-level courses on islam in black
america malcolm x prince roger nelson in
african american studies
ali is currently the oral historian at
brooklyn historical society where he
records collects and curates the spoken
word histories testimonies memoirs and
narratives of brooklynites from all
walks of life in this capacity he
currently directs the muslims in in
brooklyn a multi-year public arts and
history project designed to amplify the
histories of muslims in brooklyn
previously he served under the direction
of the late manning marable as project
manager and senior researcher the
malcolm x project at columbia university
a multi-year research initiative on the
life and legacy of malcolm x
next please welcome sana simba
born bernard sutton in washington dc
sana simba grew up in a cycle of poverty
drugs and violence that dominated inner
city life and culture in the 70s and 80s
sauna's drive and academic success got
him into the prestigious gonzaga college
high school in washington dc and
subsequently college
sana's life grew increasingly complex as
he straddled between living as a
successful entrepreneur and businessmen
by day an art and black nationalist and
pan-africanist who led radical
consciousness raising groups at night
as ceo and co-founder of carol books the
most successful independent and
black-owned bookstore chain in the u.s
sana's accumulated emotional wounds
entangled with the duplicity of his life
resulted in the devastating loss of
everything sana built you can learn more
about his story in his recent memoir
never stop he enthusiastically told me
that it was malcolm x's life and
teachings that influenced him to
co-found caribou books we will have a
book signing with simba with santa simba
following tonight's conversation
last but certainly not least please
welcome dr larue louis mccoy
dr louis mccoy
is an associate professor of sociology
of education
in the sociology of education program at
new york university's steinhardt school
of culture education and human
development
his central line of research
concentrates on educational inequality
[Laughter]
well one time for the children house you
know who their papa is
[Applause]
and i meant that in the best way
possible i realized that that could have
been taken a different way
um
his central line of research
concentrates on educational inequality
focused on the intersecting role of race
class and place
his first book inequality in the
promised land race resources and
suburban schooling examined the
experiences of low income and racial
minority families attempts at assessing
school-related resources in an affluent
suburb his larger research and interests
include race and racism gender justice
and community mobilization
after we hear from our panel we invite
the audience to join the conversation by
using the mics at the back of the room
for an audience q a with that said
please take it over dr valdez thank you
thank you all for coming this evening
[Applause]
so my understanding is that we have 45
minutes of conversation and so that's
why my phone is next to me
so i wanted to start by asking the panel
what is your entry point to malcolm x
you know i i don't want to sound cliche
but it is the autobiography um i was in
high school
uh well it's two things it's the
autobiography of malcolm x and hip hop
um i was in high school and we used to
have to do book reports and i remember
my high school teacher assigning me
a book and i was also at that point
where i was trying to understand or come
up with a way of understanding race in
america
and
um i was like i don't want to read any
more books by white people
and this is a black teacher and so shout
out to all of the public school teachers
who see
yeah
who
we see opportunities to intervene
in the lives of their students and she
intervened and said well why don't you
read the autobiography of malcolm x and
i remember it was a friday i checked the
book out from the school library and
took it home and that was my weekend
like i couldn't put the book down
you know malcolm's
just analysis of race
his experience of a student whose dreams
and aspirations were being shot down
his just evolution throughout his life
and then as a muslim
um this book also spoke to me um malcolm
represented
a publicly engaged islam um islam as a
reform islam as a revolutionary
kind of religion and i was very excited
and while i was reading the soundtrack
in my ear was public enemy
and they of course had sampled malcolm
um in party for your right to fight and
a few other tracks and
um so it was the the culture and the
um story of malcolm and at the time
malcolm came to represent a kind of
intellectual cool
um so you know people talk about how
like
being smart stigmatizes you in some
public schools like that was not my
experience because malcolm i would
always like uphold malcolm and people
would respect that so there was no like
peer pressure to not pursue learning
people were like yeah do that do that
and
so that was my my entry point to malcolm
thank you
yeah mine was uh maybe a bit uh colorful
um i grew up in dc and i in the group i
hung around i was spent a lot of time in
streets selling drugs on the gun it was
in a gang
and so i was the only guy in my group
that was able to go to a college so i
was able to escape education became my
escape route and so i sold my gun i gave
up selling drugs so i'm on this
predominantly white campus but i'm still
a street guy and if you talk about the
80s i have my fellow sweatsuit my new
balance tennis shoes
you know everything and so i'm in the
classroom
and there's a dr william lawbaugh his
writing class it was a
student very popular student and she was
teasing my addiction i took offense and
uh she was a young lady so i couldn't
threaten her directly so we got into it
in class so i told her i said well
go find one of these white boys on
campus anyone you choose and i will
punish them for you right and so the
teacher hearing the disruption poured us
out to class
and he called me to his office the next
day so i went up and he said you know
i'm ready to file a claim
on your behalf of racism against her and
see i'm from the streets i'm like well
we just should knuckle up
i mean that was what i'm proposing like
all this
you know telling the authorities that's
not how we handle things i had no
interest in filing the claim but i
appreciated the uh you know
so he said to me
he said uh
he said but you know the way you handle
things would not be the way dr king
would handle things i had heard of dr
king
and then he said i don't know why i
didn't ask him he said
have you heard of a book called soul on
ice
i've never had
so i went to the library i checked the
book out i never returned that book i
still own it right
and then when uh
you know when you
so when i ran across malcolm x the first
thing that grabbed me was the x was so
mysterious
and i was like why would somebody have
the last name x
and then when i read about him
a mother who was mentally ill was uh put
away an institution in kalamazoo
michigan his father was not in his life
because he was allegedly killed by the
black legion
my mother was mentally ill i had never
met my father and to this day i still
don't know who he was michael spent his
time on the streets i spent my time on
the streets the drugs the guns et cetera
i could relate to malcolm and it was for
the first time in my life that i met a
man either in person or through reading
who i could connect to and i wanted to
emulate him as like a father he became
like a father figure to me
and
i was on this campus and so the other
thing about malcolm the profundity the
deepness and then hearing him speak oh
my goodness i was blown away and to this
day i've never heard anyone who could
speak as effectively as malcolm
and so immediately he became my patron
saint and so the other thing about
malcolm he was all he was also cool so i
can still be street okay
and i could get good grades and so
malcolm allowed me
to transition from being a street guy to
being eventually i made the dink list
every single semester i became a part of
the student union um i start teaching
some of the teachers at the college
would actually invite me to their
classes to teach
black history to the students so malcolm
actually became like my gateway to
becoming a better person as well as
making that transition from the streets
to being in a college environment
[Applause]
i think we all have
in ways similar yet different ways of
entry to the autobiography so i was
first introduced to the autobiography
when i was starting high school and i
was going to a new school and it was a
historically white school predominantly
white very affluent and i remember them
giving me a summer reading list and i
was like what's this they were like well
you have to read in the summer and i was
like i'm not even in the school yet this
is a little bit ridiculous
and
i knew that i was going to a place that
didn't look like the schools that i've
been to there are very few black
students very few latino students and i
saw this list of about 60 books and i'm
looking down and i'm seeing things like
the iliad and the odyssey and i'm like i
have no idea what this is this doesn't
sound like me and i was like all right i
need to take this list and i need to
take it to my sister and ask her who on
this list is black
right right and so my sister who was two
years my senior was like all right i'll
find the black people there were two
books right out of 60 and those two were
the autobiography of malcolm x and james
baldwin go tell it on the mountain
and i'll be honest
at the ripe age of 15 i didn't have that
much appreciation for baldwin i was like
this language is a little bit
complicated there was more of more of a
narrative flow and i couldn't get with
it and so i was struggling with baldwin
and then i got to the autobiography
because i put down go telling on the
mountain and i picked up the
autobiography and i remember it was
around the time that my the mother my
mother's side of the family is from
selma alabama and i was in new haven
connecticut and so we were taking a trip
to selma and if and if you grew up black
in america you know often taking a trip
means getting in a car right and so we
were driving from connecticut to someone
i was like i'll take this book with me
and as i started to read the book i was
immediately wrapped up in it right i
felt connected to
him as an individual and it was a
chapter mascot that really caught me
first
because i started to think about the
environments that i've been in even when
there were a number of black students
where folks would look at me and sing me
out and be like oh yeah you're the smart
black boy right sometimes they would use
that language officially or do it
unofficially in their actions and it
didn't feel like a compliment but i
never had the language to talk about it
and so when i read that chapter i
started to think more systematically
about how education shapes and how our
teachers impact our world view and often
how the folks who are put in front of us
to educate us bring in with them sets of
prejudices and experiences and systems
of racism and so mascot opened me up and
then i started to look more at his
development and transformation and this
was the first time that i had read a
book
that
really talked about a journey and a rite
of passage for someone
someone going and moving through
different spaces having one outlook on
the world being challenged by evidence
being challenged by reality having
setbacks and changing who they were
and i was thinking
i want to change right i have folks in
my life who were black men who were
community members who were father
figures but oftentimes they were so sold
on giving me the narrative of who they
were now they wouldn't tell me about
their past
so in the autobiography i got access to
some of that past that my father and my
uncles wouldn't tell me about right and
so it started to for me it was a guide
in many ways and to this day it's
probably the book that i've gone back to
the most
because as it
as it represents an arc of change each
time i've gone back i've seen different
elements of myself
i've seen ways in which malcolm changed
that i've changed in ways in which i'm
still compelled to change so it's it's
it's it's an iterative text for me yeah
yeah i want to say i grew up with that
text in my house
so i was born and raised here in new
york city i have my parents my mother
was born in puerto rico came at 15. my
father was born in el barrio right born
in 1939 so there was no
for in my family there was no dif like
us nah we was all we was new york city
period right my father had i have uncles
who like
who ran the streets while my father was
trying to make sure that the family he
was the oldest of five to make sure that
the family was okay because my
granddaddy god bless and was running the
streets and so um
so we grew up if that text was one of
the texts that we had at home
and so i have an older sister as well
who
it was well read and so i say that
because well you know this is this is a
mixed audience in that you may be
compelled to think okay of course it
spoke to the black men on this on this
panel right it spoke to me when i read
it at 13 because one i had never
seen
articulated as you said that journey
right like the words put to it right
where i have family i was the smart kid
in my fam in my family but i also had
parents who hadn't been validated by the
educational systems who loved to read
and so that's why i had a library in the
house because
they just they they both collected books
and so it was that was our gateway right
that literacy component and what
education could promise irrespective of
what your teacher would say to you right
um
and so yeah just
that journey again
between
how he grew up in the urban centers
right of this cit of this country right
between detroit boston harlem he's
moving around a lot my family did that
as much so i related to that i also
related to i was
pleasantly surprised by
his
his forthrightness could you then talk
about folks who went to jail right you
didn't talk you much you know it was
just kind of a respectability issue
there so for this man to say no this is
this is my journey this is what i did
and yet right that promise
so
he changed obviously right he affected
and changed lives in ways that we can't
even measure because we all see we all
have emotional responses right to this
man and his journey um
and what's interesting you know a good
number of us like
you know public enemy did did something
for us and i wanted to you touched on
hip-hop so i wanted to bring it back to
that what was
what was that inflection point how did
that affect you particularly of course
spike lee's movie um public enemies
public embrace right of malcolm x again
at the time when it wasn't you know
we're coming up like the 70s and the 80s
like early 90s we see a rise of a
different kind of hip-hop right so if
y'all could speak well you know malcolm
um he spoke like a drummer
um there was a very percussive
quality to malcolm's style of delivery
it was like
whereas like martin was like a horn like
you know like a trumpet like you can
like the soaring you get and martin so
malcolm was like really fit
for
weaving in and out of break beats right
so like i think the first album or the
first track was like no sellout which
came out in like 83.
um and it was just like a break beat
with malcolm's um either message to the
grassroots of the battle i can't
remember which which of those speeches
um and that so he just you know he had
there was a musical quality um to his
speaking style and he if you listen to
his speech like he knew how to like you
know like take the
take you on this like rise
and
climax and danny malik he knew how to
play the audience as a performer and you
know he it's funny because he he was he
did moonlight as a drummer um
i think his name was carlton um
something right so
it's clear that he had that that
knowledge of like how to to deliver in a
way that was very and so like his
um his style of delivery was very much
suitable to hip hop and then his story
right which was like a northern urban
um story
fit like the whole context that hip-hop
was emerging in i mean and and even his
like it's funny like when i would teach
the the zutsu era of malcolm which
malcolm downplays the consciousness of
right but when you look at the history
of the zoot suit that like to
manufacture a zoot suit required using a
whole lot of cotton which violated the
rations during world war ii so
essentially this was like illegal
clothing
and
the ways that clothing became
criminalized
in that context and how we sometimes
look at how hip-hop uh you know
audiences or people who listen to
hip-hop or hip-hop clothes or ways of
dressing uh become criminalized i see a
lot of students just responding to the
detroit red malcolm
speaking to them
with a cultural rebelliousness maybe not
a explicitly political articulation but
culturally it is a resistance against
authority it is a rebellion against kind
of bourgeois
notions of respectability there is a
class element there and there's also a
black and brown element there because of
course the zoot and even the conking
originated from like the west coast of
like chicano culture right so
um there is so much even in that detroit
red malcolm that lend itself lent itself
so well to hip hop yeah thank you yeah
and and for me i think
malcolm's relationship to hip-hop is
he gave people
young black folks and particularly young
black men the opportunity to be angry
and intelligent yeah right yes yes the
the the ability to see yourself as
central to the community but also
question what you do to a community as
well yes and so when i would hear
uh samplings of
malcolm that's when i got introduced to
islam right so i grew up in a black
baptist household and so the first time
that i went to masa for a nation of
islam or first time i met folks from the
nation of gods and earth it all came
through hip-hop culture right and really
trying to figure out what are these
lyrics and what are they referring back
to right so who was the black man who's
the negro you know what's the five
percent and these are there there's a
whole
lineage that laid behind the words that
i encountered
at at first scratch and the more you
scratched the more you wanted to know
and so malcolm's vibrato and the way in
which he worked to create a narrative of
who he was fits really great with
hip-hop artists right hip-hop being an
art form uh particularly when the mc
comes into prominence you're seeing
folks who are trying to tell their tale
the autobiography becomes the perfect
text to pull from right now there are
hazards in that too right because if the
autobiography becomes a bible that means
the other set of texts that are also
divine or sacred or meaningful don't get
incorporated and sometimes our discourse
around malcolm can stick in a place
right so many people love the
autobiography that reading anything else
uh becomes
unacceptable yes right they're like no
no no to read that biography that's like
it's kind of haram like no actually
there are there's more than one way to
see malcolm and if there's any lesson i
think we can take from malcolm and often
one of the lessons that i challenge my
students around with hip-hop is just
because you hear a voice articulate a
thing in a moment doesn't mean they
don't have other beliefs and other ways
of understanding the world
sometimes we hold on to the dominant
image and we we forget what wraps around
the person right
right absolutely and the idea of
evolution right the idea of like this
certainly he talks about right his 20
year old self was not his 39 year old
self right um could we talk a little bit
about you again both of you mentioned
this
that this sacredness of this text right
the attachment to these words
right
um in terms of you mentioned his skill
both of you mentioned his skill as an
orator as a rhetorician right as a
performer right because there is a
certain the rhythms that one has when
you're when you're talking
so then how then do you take
that image right his voice we now have
youtube right but we have his his his
voice in in hip-hop songs
and then translate that onto a written
text this is what alex haley's challenge
was right like how do you take this
dynamic charismatic man who you know was
first introduced to most of this country
as the man who hates america right the
angriest man in america and yet
folks fell in love with him right they
were like well dang he maybe he's making
some sense maybe he's saying some things
maybe we are accountable in ways that we
hadn't really thought of right so how do
y'all how do y'all wrestle with that
tensions of the oral and the the textual
of this book well um for me um i mean it
was fairly easy because the brilliant
thing about malcolm
like for example i studied a lot of
philosophy and some philosophers you
know you may read like emmanuel khan or
something like that and you may have to
read it three or four times to
understand like what he's trying to say
or like schopenhauer then sometimes you
realize that maybe they don't understand
what they're taught
so um
malcolm
his brilliance in that uh his
profoundness also was in his simplicity
he could take very complex
ideas and break it down and speak to a
group of people in harlem the
downtrodden uneducated he could also go
to harvard michigan state all around
howard university and speak to anybody
almost anywhere and so for me it was
very easy to understand malcolm and to
put that into writing with impacting my
writing and just he was radical
he was for the downtrodden
working class he was revolutionary so me
coming from the streets i could relate
because i felt there was some degree of
guilt because i lost some friends from
the streets
and i felt like i had to give back and
so i wanted to i saw that the system was
unfair overall and when i ran into
malcolm and his fight for fundamental
change in the system he wasn't about
just like a simple reform he wanted to
either overthrow or overhaul the system
and so that appealed to me because
a part of my mission
was to
come back and
fight for people who had not had an
opportunity to receive the education i
was fortunate enough to have i was the
only guy my group who went to private
school and my mother somehow convinced
the archdiocese to finance my education
all my other friends went to public
school and my best friend didn't even
finish junior high school
so again i had this
you know this commitment to uplift and
malcolm again was my like my symbol he
was my my god in that in that regard so
and then in terms of musically i'm from
dc
and i have to admit i mean
i know everything hip-hop is from new
york
there was a time in the early 80s
very early 80s when i'm from dc go go
music
of course like right here of course and
maybe i'm still a little upset that
hip-hop is all around the world
and go-go is like still localized y'all
probably heard of chuck brown but you
know and so
i came back to malcolm through jazz okay
yeah um when i ran into john coltrane
yeah when i first heard jazz it was just
too much going on for me but then i ran
into y'all cold train naima i love
ballads but then when the cassette tapes
if y'all remember cassette tapes i would
be busy driving and i would you know be
focusing on the road
and
i would forget to fast forward past
naima or two name then i fell in love
with uh my favorite things and you know
i mean i just fell in love with john
coltrane and he played it really really
hard and so when i got into jazz i
realized like john coltrane like malcolm
kind of revolutionized jazz and once he
played that saxophone at tenor sax
i mean he completely changed the game
because he was like the malcolm x of
jazz and so and then when i started
reading about john coltrane and him
being in new york in the 60s and you
know whether he had actually seen
malcolm x speak like his impact on
malcolm or malcolm's impact on him so
when i got into jazz it kind of brought
malcolm back to me from that vantage
point musically yeah and then
i'll talk about earth in the fire later
[Laughter]
what's interesting
when you look at the manuscript
that's here that the the early draft of
the autobiography um that alex haley was
working with and you see the
the marginal comments notes that malcolm
is making and alex haley is making
there's several portions in the
autobiography where alex haley is like
crossing out and saying stop
speechifying
um you know show don't tell
embed this in the story or there's a
story that better illustrates this
and i think that brings up the tension
that you mentioned of how do you
bring the brilliance of the orality of
malcolm
in a literary
which is a very linear
right
like a literary story you know most
stories have like
in literature have a very linear kind of
presentation or i mean they're people
like you know
like tony morrison does the floating
narrator or faulkner or whatever and you
kind of like which switching like first
person second person third person but
generally speaking the writing
of a story kind of brings a structure to
it
that orality doesn't require right so
people can like they can do that
improvisation improvisational
storytelling and come back and get the
refrain and so you remember what they
were talking about then they go off and
then they come back and then they go off
and it like you can follow that rhythm
much easier in speaking that you can't
necessarily in writing and so you get
this tension in the text between alex
haley and his desire to construct a
linear narrative
and malcolm and his desire to kind of
like tell his story
and what's what's even more challenging
is that malcolm's perspective changes in
the course of the storytelling and
normally you know when someone is doing
like a memoir they have to like fix
their time and like i'm going to tell
the story from this day
because every time we tell our story we
are actually inventing our history right
and how we remember today today might
not be how we remember today next week
might not be how we remember today next
year because different things change the
meaning of today
and malcolm began the autobiography as a
tribute
to the teachings of the honorable elijah
muhammad and the salvation that he found
in those teachings and while he's doing
that um he of course becomes
disillusioned with the ombre elijah
muhammad and it becomes a very different
text and it's really hard to see how
that weaves in and out but he slips in
foreshadowing and there's parts where
alex is like don't don't don't spoil it
yet like you know like you have to like
build up tension because the um you know
like you could you can be a passive
listener right like someone can tell
their story and you really should be an
active listener but you could just sit
there and hear what we have to say but
to read like that has to you have to be
motivated to turn the page right right
and so alex haley has just now funked
this like this you know responsibility
to make this a page-turning story
right
it's a different motivation so that
tension is in the autobiography and that
isn't even to speak of the the multiple
voices
just the the format was a challenge for
malcolm and he
you know he wasn't really fond of the
autobiography as a genre because that is
about a single person
and he was trying to tell the story of
the people through his single-person
story and it's kind of like that problem
of example right like how are you
going to be the example without being
the exception right because at some
point you want to be so
standoutish that people are like this is
the example but if you're too exemplary
then people are like i can't relate to
this right and so there's this dance
that uh malcolm is trying to ground his
story in like a community story and that
tension is also
present you can see in the notes that
they're they're going back and forth
with in the in the margins of the
manuscript yeah and i think you you
touch on something that artillery
schomburg wrote about and the negro digs
up his past right he talks about how the
exception means that like you will be
taken away
from the group yeah so even while you
are trying to acknowledge the group and
you are part of this community you come
out of this community but the moment
that someone says oh wait
and when we say someone oftentimes that
means
the larger dominant mainstream white
culture as malcolm x lived right we
talked about like he was living he was
given speeches around the world right he
was given speeches not only in this in
this country at some of the finest
universities but he was at oxford he was
he was doing he was deemed as the
exception so the fact that he was always
continually invoking the honorable
elijah muhammad right as if to say no no
this is what grounds me my spirituality
grounds me right and resisting and yet
by the time we get to the actual
composition of the text
we see the change in their relationship
right right i just wanted to like throw
mr schamberg's name in that i didn't
forget you
no i love when you break down schaumburg
one of the finest books on him yet so
thank you
for for me i think about what alex haley
had to do with this text yes right so
originally he's supposed to be the
co-author supposed to be malcolm x and
alex haley and then
ostensibly we assume that alex ellie met
malcolm and was like wow this is really
powerful cat but we believe some very
different things right and he he wasn't
a known author he wasn't a known
quantity at that point so he's like how
about you make it as told to right and
so he takes on kind of like a secondary
or passive role but one of the things
that really stuck out to me in reading
what some folks call like one of the
missing chapters was the difference in
the voice right yes so that chapter was
delivered about a month and a half
before
malcolm makes the comments about the
chickens coming home to roost right and
it's a very fiery chapter it's it's
almost as if if you've watched malcolm's
speech it's punchy it's like really deep
it's like i could imagine i could see
him teaching in mass number seven and
you're being like what is the negro this
is the negro and this is the true black
man right and it's and it's so in your
face
and that was supposed to be the
structure right or kind of central to
the book and i don't actually think if
that had if that truck structure had
held up that we would
appreciate or have the autobiography
that we have today
in fact haley had to do
a lot of massaging
and and pressing of malcolm to tell his
tale
to really make it a story for us right
so i think that alex haley
in spite of some of his political
beliefs and maybe even political paid
affiliations right he's a powerful griot
yeah because he takes a story
and he honors what what has come but he
weaves it so everyone who's at the feet
of it gets something yes and gets
something in in time immemorial and that
for me is a phenomenal act yes yeah we
all had to read the law the last chapter
right in preparation for this
conversation i wanted to ask you all
what your reactions were to it um was
there anything in there that surprised
you
that i mean certainly we are always
asked when we talk about historical
figures what would they think today how
does this apply today my own personal
reaction was how very timely
that that chapter was and how sadly
those things it's a it's a it's ongoing
conversation right um the idea of
questions about community questions
about consumption right cultural
consumption capitalist consumption
in the
way that in a way to define yourself um
in a way to be
acceptable or respected in this culture
right he's dealing with all of that he's
also dealing with um
what folks need to do in terms of
organizing and mobilizing right and
political activism and
we have to get to how to incorporate
folks who don't vote right how do we be
attractive to folks who don't vote so
that we can be taken seriously as a
voting bloc
so just wondering your thoughts about
that chapter well um in my reading of it
uh one thing that surprised me towards
the end he was saying we need to start
taking action and he pointed out that
around that time there were about 20
million
afro-americans or black people in the
country were eight million adults so
eight million votes and most of those
people did not vote
and he was saying that um in 1960
election that kennedy won
by about 115 000 votes he was like hey
black folks could have
elected nixon instead of kennedy and so
he also pointed out there was some
contradiction with kennedy he kept
talking about how much he loved black
people but once he got in office it took
him three years and it wasn't until
black folks got upset in alabama and
started responding to the violence that
they were experiencing and then in
birmingham and that's when he said he's
going to put out the civil rights bill
so he exposed kennedy on in that front
but he was uh really saying look we have
a power block a political block that we
can use that kind of surprised me that
uh that's the way that he was pointing
it out in that particular chapter and
dr ali has made the point and i saw that
as well how many times he kept trying to
tell um
you know how he was going to prison i
went back and read some of the
autobiography that was published and he
kept trying to
tip his hat
to the reader that hey i've gone to
prison and alex haley i think his
involvement
made the autobiography more of a
personal story as opposed to political
treaties and i think what alex did what
mr haley had done and said look the
power is in the subtlety of the story
you have to tell your story and through
your life and everything you've been
through everyone can relate to it you
don't have to say that what black folks
have been through here and why black
folks have been through this and we have
to deal with the white devil or change
the system just by telling your story
and people relating to
what they've experienced similar to
yours they can see the suffering you
don't have to actually say it
like in a preaching sort of way just
tell your story and i think alex haley's
involvement was very helpful in that
regards because he
held malcolm back and the beauty just
like you watch the spike lee movie
sometimes despite you guys give him
credit he was great in terms of um
pioneering sometimes he beat you over
the head with the message boom boom
malcolm the same thing yes you just pull
it back
you're not behind the podium you're not
giving a speech in harlem you're telling
your story so he had to pull that out of
malcolm and then you get all of the jazz
the billie holiday donna washington
billy eckstein get all of this stuff
coming out of malcolm and then you can
relate to malcolm you know then he
becomes one of us he's not up
up high right we see some of the
frailties of malcolm
[Applause]
for me the chapter was very striking in
that the voice of it was really an
internal dialogue it's entitled the
negro and it's directed at black folks
exclusively right and he's literally
talking about the ways in which uh
negro has a category of folks who have
sold themselves out who have bought into
an idea of white integration and white
possibility and he he does address a
white audience one of the things that i
think is so smart about it is he's like
you know these negro leaders are
financed by white folks are trotted out
by white folks in all these ways and if
i was white i would be pissed
because these negro leaders who tell you
they have their finger on the pulse of
black people couldn't tell you that
black folks were about to rise up right
couldn't tell you that black folks were
already pissed off in fact they kept on
telling you things were all right right
and malcolm was like the fact of the
matter is who white folks think is
leading black people is not at all right
so he tells an adage of uh uh uh an
adage of a group of black folks who are
marching down the street and the negro
leader shows up and he's running
alongside of them and and he's like hey
y'all like
i can't lead you if you don't tell me
where we're going right
and that's like quintessential malcolm
right but really talking about this
leadership class and the ways in which
black folks here may have bankrupted
ourselves of potential power so he does
that in part through
though i don't agree with everything in
his assessment right a conversation
around immigration right and what it is
that uh black folks here have not done
that other groups have done or may do so
he goes from irish folks to jewish folks
to
folks from the continent and so he kind
of starts to say hey look if we take
these pieces we can regain our political
power and it is in part through
strategic electoral politics that will
do this so it's kind of often
represented that
the split with the nation of islam pole
split malcolm became much more
interested in electoral politics that
pre-pre-split in the noi he thought
about politics but not
explicitly but this chapter really says
he was thinking about a black voting
bloc he was talking about those eight
million black folks who didn't vote but
he wasn't shaming them right you're
saying in fact they have a reason not to
vote right right he said to black folks
democratic republicans don't they mean
the same thing they mean nothing right
and he said if there is a leader who can
get those folks to vote it's the
honorable elijah muhammad right and he's
saying what we need to do is follow the
honorable elijah muhammad and then make
those politicians respond to a set of
questions which will really induce a
black voting bloc and will be courted
right
now before
we know before the autobiography comes
to pass and before his death he splits
from elijah muhammad but the seeds of
politics the seeds of talking about
political incorporation and the seeds of
tough talk but also loving talk are
there right and sometimes our critiques
whether we be conscious whether we vote
whether we be african with a k sometimes
we can talk down and the love gets lost
yes and i don't think malcolm ever lost
the love right now
you know there's this there's one
passage that i i highlighted where he
says in that chapter he says the true
nature and then the true intent of the
form of slave masses glaring every way
and every day in the headlines and then
he has like a line for each of these
right you can't enter here
you can't ride here you can't work here
you can't play here you can't study here
you can't eat here you can't drink here
you can't walk here you can't live here
and immediately thought of eric garner i
can't breathe right
and all of the in the last four or five
years all of the various black lives of
people who have found themselves in
places where they just can't be black
and be
whether it's shopping or at a pool or at
a barbecue or you know selling lemonade
on the side of the street or whatever
the it's the you can't and you know
malcolm had this kind of brilliance
um of being able to
um
speak
what people were experiencing but maybe
weren't able to speak for themselves
right so
it isn't that he gave voice to the
voiceless because people had voices he
just amplified the voices that he
himself had collected
over his travels and that's one of the
reasons why he resonated so powerfully
um you know this chapter the negro is
it's rough i mean you said he says it
would love but like the first like 10
pages of it right he's like located no
he's like he's like you know white
people will have a cadillac after they
have a cadillac house after they have a
cadillac job their cadillac bank account
but but us we have a cadillac car first
before the house before the and it's
like yeah you know like he was there is
a i mean and this is part of the black
nationalist tradition right which is
assuming that we are in the same
community so i can speak which is like
this is family talk right
and
but it also embraces
a deficient
view of black america right a
pathologized view of black america that
is so damaged by the experience of
slavery and jim crow racism that is in
need of repair and i think you know if
you go too hard on that then you you
kind of don't leave people with any kind
of sense of their own resources with
which to you know to to resolve this i
mean the truth of the matter is if
malcolm wanted to use a migrant
narrative he could have used the
narrative of migrants from the south to
the north which proved themselves just
as enterprising just as economically
organizing just as culturally in fact
the nation of islam is arisen out of
southern migrants to the north so you
didn't have to like look at people who
were coming to the united states the
immigrant or the migrant ethos is very
much present in black america that we
don't have to feel like we are losing
something we just have to find that
historical moment where it's there and i
feel that that's the you know i was just
like
you know when i was reading this because
um it was he was really beating you know
really beating us up um and and i felt
like that is um within the spectrum of
the black freedom movement you find in
you know there's a kind of declension
narrative right this idea that we
we have fallen right and this notion
that we have fallen is premised on some
nostalgic golden era whether it was you
know well during slavery people were
able to do this or you know back in
africa we were doing this and um i think
that that sometimes robs us of the
progress narrative right um not to be
falsely optimistic but also to
understand that like no we are making
progress as a people and of course if
you're trying to like bring an urgency
to folks you you bring the apocalypse is
here right like the world has come to an
end um i mean it's essentially a make
black america great again right that is
the declension there no it is
right and um that's what you know golden
age nationalism had as one of its strong
elements i mean the idea that the
original man was this that and the next
and had been had fallen and let us come
back kind of sometimes robs us of the
resources we have you know with us now
but i think it
[Applause]
i think i think it also speaks to our
lost histories i.e there are we have a
history of black folks
we have always
part of the the
expansion of this country meant that
black folks were in the west and we
don't ha in the 18th and 19th centuries
we don't have those right there you have
to look for those you have to look for
now painter you have to look for you
know scholars who have done this work
and go oh wait we did set up you know a
record number of newspapers like black
owned newspapers it wasn't just the
defender and the amsterdam news and the
curry it was we had hundreds of
newspapers right we had black businesses
there was a black wall street there was
you know and so i when what struck me
when i when i was reading his words was
that right like he doesn't call on that
like wait we do have this and it's lost
even to him yeah right yeah he literally
no go go no there's a moment where he
mentions like benevolent societies among
european communities and i'm like that's
our stuff literally absolutely that's
how we got free yeah in many ways right
and so whether it's freemasons or the
elks or i mean we have these groups
right and so i thought that was really
interesting and as well and when i saw
that litany that you just did i i social
media and on twitter when everything
pops off at any given moment there's a
recording of oh we can't go to the pool
oh we can't go shopping oh we can't go
the airbnb or we can't go and so that
was again the the tragedy for me was
damn
like we're still here yes there's a
progress there yes yes and yet at the
same time white supremacy is going to do
what it does it's also making progress
how well yeah how about that that's the
way
we have two more minutes of conversation
here but i did want to say for those of
you as you're starting to think about
questions that the microphones are in
the back
um
so with this being our final set um is
there anything that
you wanted to say about this text about
this lost chapter about this man and his
and his words his living legacy as we
commemorate his assassination on this
day
i would say
i was happy to see when i googled
autobiography when i typed in
autobiography malcolm x's autobiography
was the first book to come up i was
pleased with that um
i would say that
saying
pretty certain that malcolm outgrew the
nation of islam it became his you know
it saved him it gave him a foundation
but he was extremely intelligent not
only that he was uh his soul he was
elevated as a human being very spiritual
being being a seventh child um
and
he didn't betray us like
like for example elijah muhammad i mean
you find out i think malcolm one of the
things that it kind of upsets me and
every time i would watch the documentary
on malcolm x by honor pearl that came
out in 72 and you get to the
assassination piece and
they interviewed some of the harlemites
after the uh assassination you know i
get teary uh
that's how emotional emotionally
connected i am to malcolm i think a lot
of people feel that way especially new
yorkers um
and the thing that um
that hurts me is that i'm like
malcolm should have left like as soon as
he found out that elijah muhammad was a
sexual predator like why didn't he leave
but then i think that well he probably
saw elijah as like a father figure it
probably made it difficult for malcolm
to leave his father his spiritual father
in effect and the thing that that i'm
amazed by him is that at the very end
like you could tell he wasn't a selfish
person you couldn't buy him dr john
henry clark talks about this uh i think
a muslim country or some muslim group
wanted to
offer malcolm over a million dollars and
he turned it down he would not be used
in that way i mean if he was really not
for
people in general but black people in
particular i mean his life was on the
line and i recall benjamin karim who was
like one of his right-hand men and the
muslim mosque incorporated recounted uh
that bumpy johnson who people in harlem
know about one of the legendary
gangsters came to malcolm and said look
man i heard you have a problem with the
nation i can handle that for you now you
know
and michael was like hey
i don't want to see two black groups
fight
and even at even with his life on the
line he still would not fight
and uh i think that's amazing and uh he
gave his life
and so
that to me he was revolutionary he was
radical and i think you may have said it
earlier
that he still was loving and kind so
those two those things are mutually
exclusive right so uh you know so i
think that's the thing that stands out
to me that he was he was loving yeah
thank you
[Applause]
for me i think um revisiting the
autobiography
reminds me that malcolm was a principled
man
right but principle doesn't equal
perfect
right
the way that many of us talked about
coming to the autobiography and what
attracted us and probably many of us in
this room was kind of the dirt that was
on malcolm right right the things that
he did in his past and his attempts to
clean himself up and clean his people up
right
sometimes what happens when you get to
the end of the autobiography is that
folks have created a perfected figure
right and then that means any discussion
of um malcolm
becomes uh any critique of malcolm is
actually unallowable because he's
unassailable which is not what i believe
he would have wanted at all right the
man went around the globe debating
people he was constantly trying to
refine himself he was constantly trying
to find what was better for me i want
folks to reread revisit the
autobiography i want them to read around
malcolm i want them to be able to find
themselves in his narrative and figure
out the places where they may need to
change their narrative around malcolm so
they can change themselves yeah right
too often i think he becomes a deified
figure but we need him to be divine but
divine enough to touch and transform us
again yeah amen
[Applause]
you know malcolm's autobiography is a
story of self but it's also a story of
us
and it's also a story of urgency of like
what needs to be done
um but reading the autobiography in the
context of the manuscript
and this chapter the negro
um
i come away with a reminder of how how
it is a construction
it is a product it is a product that is
a collaboration between malcolm and
hayley
and after malcolm has you know been
killed haley has to complete the book
and so it's a collaboration between
haley and his editors right and that
isn't to take away from the authenticity
of the autobiography but it is to
acknowledge that when we tell our
stories we choose what facts of our past
are important in that moment and we also
choose what not to say and so i think
when you you talked about like find
yourself in malcolm but also find
yourself in the silences of malcolm
right the mount there are things that
malcolm doesn't talk about and that
doesn't mean they aren't relevant to
the struggle right
malcolm's views of women
um do not shift radically in the
autobiography but they do shift
radically in his life right right that's
right by the time he establishes the
organization of afro-american unity he
is very comfortable having women lead
that organization or take the a prime
role in that organization that is not
reflected in the autobiography um the
autobiography is like you know you can't
trust women they will trap you
you know i think he gets to one point
he's like i you know the the one woman
that i trusted is betty and i only trust
her halfway or something like that right
like it's very like is deeply
patriarchal right and you know i think
that's not something i picked up on
obviously as a young man reading it i
was like yeah
but
but i think that we have to
we have to you know see the silences and
what isn't said and then be able to fill
it in with our own story as well that we
do kind of have to build on this text it
was written by someone who was born in
1925
and was killed in
1965 like it is unfair for us to make
this a trans-historical
eternal
revelation it is not right and if we're
willing to contextualize scripture then
we need to contextualize the
autobiography of malcolm x
[Applause]
we have questions
so we have folks standing up i will say
i will ask you all one we'll probably
because we have a limited amount of time
we'll probably take three questions at
the same time
and then we'll try to answer them so
it'll be one two three
right and then the panel will try the
answer
is that all right november that sounds
like a great idea okay
[Laughter]
so how y'all doing uh my name is oh i'm
sorry just one more thing we want to
keep them to questions so that we can go
ahead and get through as many of them as
possible thank you okay so malcolm x
talked about the fascination between the
white woman and the black man as well as
the fascination between the black man
and the white woman i just graduated
from college first person in my family
to go to vanderbilt hey
in that college i saw a lot of this
similar issues so i just wanted to know
if you guys see it today as well okay
one second question
do you think that
malcolm's zealotry
blinded him from
elijah muhammad's
relationships with the young girls
and at the same time was that at that
same time period he defied elijah
muhammad's orders as far as speaking out
on kennedy and a couple other things and
that seemed to be the downfall it all
happened like in a very short period of
time
okay
and we'll do one more okay good evening
i have a statement really i don't have
okay so we're gonna hold right there
we'll take those first two questions one
the uh
the gentleman uh relates to elijah
muhammad and malcolm i think it's a bit
more complex than that you also when you
talk about elijah muhammad and malcolm
you have to also talk about elijah
muhammad's family there was always i
think a certain degree of jealousy there
with the possible exception of maybe
like a dwarf dean muhammad or wallace
muhammad and so
elijah muhammad's family were in elijah
muhammad's ear a lot
and so
they were
trying to
gold elijah muhammad into kind of
severing ties with malcolm
and also
i think
that
malcolm was so
sincere in his approach and i think he
discovered that elijah muhammad wasn't
so sincere of course there was some i
think he was blind to some extent but i
think he was really disappointed that
elijah muhammad wasn't as serious about
what he preached as he really was and so
um and then you have to mention the fbi
and they were doing certain things to
kind of take advantage of the tension
for example elijah muhammad was
sensitive about his age so the fbi would
have journalists who were either on the
payroll or influence and they would
write articles about
malcolm and stress his
age his youth and versus elijah
muhammad's age
and that would make elijah muhammad
upset and they would since they were
bugging and
hearing everything they knew to take
advantage of that to create that schism
which ultimately led to his
assassination
did he hear you once a while white women
why do you do that
actually i have i don't have any
expertise
and you don't want to know what that is
the answer that you should have whenever
you do not have the proper information
to answer that's right
i tell my students i don't know that
um
i miss that but i'm gonna answer the
question right so
um so malcolm often talks about this
fascination of the distant the desirable
but unattainable this is part and parcel
with white supremacy that's not new we
still have that existing today but when
we look at the numbers right like i
think it's around 88 to 89 of black
women have black men as partners right
so sometimes the thing that we see in
minority can become so
gleaming and take our attention that we
miss what is probably the most regular
thing black love exists
it has before and it continues to exist
so so that's where my focus is i you
know i'm not worried about that that's
just not my sexual worry
see you with this all right we'll take
two more questions hi um i'd like to
know you all's take
on malcolm x's history as a queer sex
worker specifically i'd like your
comments on the veracity of those claims
as well as their strategic exclusion
from mainstream conversations like this
one about malcolm x
and the second question
if you don't have one sorry anything um
i was giving waving to sister aisha
salaamwalekum
um i just want to give my son ismail a
chance to ask a question
how was maximex's
his kid or him
like
him malcolm x
what was he like as a kid i think that's
okay and i would also just throw into
that on with ismail that question is
when i was young when i read it the the
beginning of it
was like this ecological
masterpiece and it described his
relationship to the natural world
and so i'm just curious about ismail's
question and my question okay well on
the uh homosexuality piece um
you know i've read that and for me
like for example my book i'm an open
book i think it's
that vulnerability actually is a sign of
strength it's not a sign of weakness and
i think for men traditionally we're not
it's not supposed to be vulnerable but i
think we need to kind of get away from
that but when i read that so
whether malcolm has sex with somebody in
his marriage out his marriage or
homosexual encounter when he was young
that doesn't in any way impact his
greatness when i read that my only issue
was that i didn't see enough evidence to
for
that to be cited i would need a little
more evidence to cite something that
significant about his sexual uh activity
that was my only concern about it
whether it was true or not i really
don't care
so i'll weigh in so i think that
sex work has been around and plenty of
folks that we know and love participated
in sex work and there is evidence from
malcolm that he engaged in sex work now
hearing lies the rub we we allow certain
forms of sex work to be accepted on
their face somebody says i was pimped
they're like cool you were a pimp
somebody says oh they were a powder boy
and they did this well i need three
witnesses i need 15 transcripts and they
all have to confirm and that's where i
think really heteronormativity comes
into play right in our notions of gender
absolutely i i think if the burden of
evidence is there then put it everywhere
if not then i'm saying okay we're not
dealing with really the complexity of
people's lives and their fullness right
yeah well and i think also again there
is something to be said about
how if people have this emotional
reaction if for example we're talking
about someone who
people feel like they're their father
right
then then it that's what we're
oh you found out something that like
maybe you don't know how to deal with
and it does
we have to have those conversations and
we have to say if all black lives matter
then all black lives matter and then we
have to deal with okay how does this
if he if he did sex work with men which
is what is that is
then how do we feel about that right and
guess what we don't feel anything about
that because you guess what this man has
been god bless him you know but he's
been gone for a little bit so now
why is it more of a problem to have
engaged in that than to have to with him
being a pimp
why is that like oh we we're okay with
exploitation of women
but you know
this part
okay
and so the other question about malcolm
x as a little a young man as well as i'm
sorry i didn't recall the other part of
yours
so i'll just say put in a plug for a
wonderful book that i read to my
daughters which is malcolm little which
is the story of malcolm x uh written by
his daughter that talks about him
growing up his relationship to his
parents and kind of the challenges that
he faced when he was no longer able to
live with them how he he met teachers
and other folks who sometimes told him
that he wasn't allowed to be
a lawyer he wasn't allowed to do certain
things because he was black but his
fight to be whole and to be loved so
it's a wonderful book yeah and if you
don't have it i got you
my name is beverly copeland under the
old soviet system
uh voting was strongly encouraged they
had extremely high voter participation
rates because constitutionally under the
old soviet system
the the control of the whole political
system
was in the hands of the political elites
under the american constitution state
federal and local the state charters the
fed the local charters
uh
voter participation
is
suppressed
by both democrats and republicans when
you vote you're essentially
voting for
rubber you're just rubber stamping
candidates selected by the the
leadership in the democratic and
republican party i don't vote as a
result
if malcolm had succeeded if the black
panthers had succeeded if king had
succeeded in organizing at a grassroots
level that would have allowed for
meaningful voting in america because you
would not just be rubber stamping
candidates or
of of the the higher uh the the elites
in the democratic or republican party
you would be voting for your choice
so
i want to say
that
is there a question the question is what
do you think it will take
for
the american system to really be
democratic and really be grassroots
really be bottoms up thank you and your
question
all right so like uh members of the
panel my love affair with malcolm began
in um as a teenager reading the
autobiography when i was 15. and that
love of air was kind of sustained as
you've talked about through hip-hop
by seeing the images of malcolm seeing
his words in boogie damn productions and
x-clan and and uh
um
all these other groups that just really
kind of spoke to me spoke to my culture
spoke to my time period and brought
malcolm um into that time period
so
obviously the hip-hop off today is
different
i'm not going to say it's better or
worse it's definitely worse but
it's
but
i i do wonder you know
for a young man like myself obviously
who didn't live during the time that
malcolm was alive but was able to again
have that sustained through
hip-hop and through
other means of accessing
malcolm
how do you see young people today
to be able to access my malcolm how do
you see his words right the images of
malcolm and all the other ways that we
have were influenced when we were
younger how did that happen today how do
you think young people can access
malcolm because i don't i don't see it
in or hear it in the music it's not
something that i see kind of being as
prevalent as it was when i was a young
man
whatever i'll take the other one um it's
interesting the you can actually trace
the representations of malcolm
um in hip-hop from a very literal
his voice
to
metaphors right so you go from no
sellout which samples his actual voice
to someone like kanye west saying buy
any genes necessary like bui right so
that by any means necessary has become
an act of of conspicuous consumption
um or
um i can't remember the artist who
compares malcolm to a car right like
naming like his car uh
you know after malcolm or the appeal of
really detroit red
more than malcolm x
and i think that just reflects you know
i think it's
we can't put on
certainly someone who is not with us but
we can't put on malcolm the burden
of transforming hip-hop or transforming
our culture
we have to make that choice right
whether it is through our
decision of what to patronize
um our decision of what to celebrate
what to uphold um you know matt malcolm
is not like some magic totem who's like
the you if you play a malcolm x speech
like no because they're like no you know
there it it was in it wasn't just people
went in and heard malcolm and they woke
up people heard malcolm in a context
right if you went into a nation of islam
they didn't just let you hear malcolm
walk out the door they gave you some
forms that you had to fill out they they
gave you some structure some
institutional culture
that you know gave you some stuff that
you had to do you had meetings to go to
on monday on wednesday on thursday on
sunday like they gave a whole like
structure to your life right that was
the transformative power
that accompanied malcolm's voice right
and even when he left he he understood
the need to build institutions so he
built muslim mosque inc he established
the organization of afro-american union
they never had a chance to really get up
off the ground but he really understood
that his uh charisma and even elijah
right like if anybody ever heard elijah
speak like he was not malcolm but
there was this one i think it was just
one writer who like goes into to follow
malcolm shadow malcolm and it's like a
meeting in armory in new york city and
malcolm opens up the meeting and people
are like you know cheering and the
reporter is like okay i get it i get it
and then elijah steps to the microphone
and the place goes bananas and the
reporter is like what
right because elijah was like
institutionalized charisma right which
was
the way to pope is institutionalized
charisma like you don't understand the
language of the poetry but you know that
there's something important there
there's something no i'm serious like
james baldwin said like when he sat with
elijah he understood the power of him
right and so we have to understand that
hip-hop is not just a song
the culture is an institution and we
have to treat our culture as a product
of institutions whether it be record
companies radio stations you know all of
the kind of accompanying things that
make a cultural phenomena attractive
this is not i'm not a conspiracy
theories but culture is produced right
it is a production and we should
understand that
if we want to change the product we have
to deal with the sites of production
[Applause]
[Laughter]
anybody going to respond to the politics
yeah um
the question of what it would take to
politically activate everyone is a
question that we've been dealing with
now for literally uh a hundred years
what i will say is that
we have to think about multiple levels
of political engagement and it's not a
single organization that's going to
transform this right we need a
radically different understanding of how
we understand democracy and what we read
and how we engage because even if folks
were successful in in activating people
to get out to vote for slate of
candidates with systems and institutions
like the electoral college there are
limits on that right without an
understanding of local politics what
city council does there are limits on
what we can do so it is about finding
candidates but it's also about political
literacy in a very different format one
which i think some organizations do well
organizations like movement for black
lives
are doing some of that work and so
that's who i look for for that potential
not necessarily
a political organization that does not
start with a framework of saying
electoral politics are essential for our
movement
so we have two more questions but right
before we get to those last two
questions i just want to say a couple of
things one i definitely recommend people
revisiting our conversation women speak
about malcolm x which is curated by
sister aisha
on may 19 2016. you can find it on
livestream.com
schomburg center um i know that that was
part of sort of the last part of the
conversation before we went to q a and
also as people are leaving just waiting
to remind you that we do have the
autobiography of malcolm x available in
our schomburg shop also we have never
stop which is simba asana's
memoir and he will be signing that
afterwards because clearly this brother
has a story to tell
and so if you wanted to read more about
his story
i highly recommend that so with that we
have sister aisha and then we have one
more question after her
i'd like to thank the panel for
a very
thoughtful conversation this evening
and daring to touch on some subjects
that are not always popular uh to
address but do it we must uh as uh
historians
professors
activists and others
my only plea
to you
is that when we make assertions about
people
who have
set
a path before us a liberation path that
when we bring assertions
about
such persons as malcolm x and others
whatever they may be that it becomes
incumbent
on you
to produce
the evidence
the substantiation
the evidence and the proof of such uh
assertions uh so that we can stay true
to our mission
of speaking truth to power so again i
thank you for your comments sir thank
you so much
[Applause]
well i just wanted to ask like what was
the start to the path of malcolm x's
death
um
substantiate your assertion here now wow
yeah
um you know i i think um
you talked about the complexity you know
malcolm was very much
a co-creator of a lot of the nation of
islam's culture
and he
bore some of the responsibility
for in fact he was going to introduce
the honorific the honorable elijah
muhammad before it was mr muhammad right
and he was the one who taught this
loyalty to the honorable elijah muhammad
to the point where people would
bring
hurt
to folks that violated that loyalty
some of which malcolm may have presided
over as a minister of the mosque
so the question is
when did this process start right
in 1959 elijah muhammad went to make
umrah which was the the hajj the
pilgrimage not in the hodge season and
he left malcolm in charge in chicago
and malcolm began cleaning house
which was the first it was there was two
things that happened from that
experience one
it was clear that elijah was
priming malcolm
for this leadership position should
anything happen to him right
it was clear that he was you know put
this faith and confidence in malcolm not
his children right
and the second thing that came out of
that was that the children saw what
malcolm would do
and they decided people in chicago
decided that we can't have
malcolm x be the
successor
so one could say that that began one of
the
one of the strings that led the thread
of malcolm's death the other is the fbi
we can't forget
that the federal government relentlessly
pursued malcolm and the nation of islam
and black organizations from their very
beginning
that even while malcolm was in prison
his file was created
his first the first page of his first
fbi file was created while he was in
prison protesting
for the treatment of prisoners in prison
and that when he traveled around the
country to set up mosques
for example when he had a mosque meeting
or organizing meeting in boston in
somebody's private home where about a
dozen people were in attendance one
person in attendance reported on that
meeting to the fbi
and this was in 1952. so
that is a important that i would say if
the other things of the the disputes
within the nation of islam
were the threads that are you know we
look at the beginning of the thread for
the the the core of that rope
is the the federal
government the new york police
department the bureau of special
services or bossy
and you know we should be very
mindful
that this you know just you look at the
fbi declaring you know black identity
extremists going after black lives
matter you know we look at the
um discord sometimes that appears in
social media amongst various activists
in the black lives various forms of
black lives matter and we think that's
personal beef well what do you think
people thought was going on between
elijah and malcolm personal beef but
behind the scenes as you pointed out the
fbi was stoking this they were
exacerbating this we know they did it
with the panthers they'd send you a
letter allegedly by me talking about you
and then they'd send me a letter
allegedly by you talking about me and
then when we meet i'm giving you the
side eye because i got your letter but
you never wrote it right right and so i
think we have to when we talk about you
know the thread we can talk about you
know look j edgar hoover's first
career making job cause he was like
attorney in the attorney general's
office the first case that he built his
career on was the deportation of marcus
garvey
right and so we could start there
with that thread
i want to say thank you to
everyone who participated in the q a and
absolutely everybody on our stage let's
give everyone here a round of applause